[Music]
sing it mary mary j blige followed her
super bowl halftime performance by
hitting the stage at the naacp image
awards with her song good morning
gorgeous you know mary also won
outstanding supporting actress in a
drama for power book 2 ghost for the
second year in a row she is so good in
that show meanwhile it was an naacp
first for prince harry and meghan markle
the duke and duchess of sussex
i think it's safe to say that i come
from a very different background than my
incredible wife
yet our lives were brought together for
a reason
we share a commitment to a life of
service and i couldn't be prouder that
we're doing this work together
megan and harry accepted the president's
award for their work in social justice
and megan brought a special guest my
mom's here with us tonight and we all
feel very proud thank you
from halle berry to host anthony
anderson and his mama to zendaya rocking
not one but two different looks
boyfriend tom holland commenting of
course the stars came to play megan good
told me she's staying strong two months
after her divorce filing from devon
franklin it's been challenging and it's
been a lot
but
all i can do is trust god you know this
is amazing
big winners issa rae jennifer hudson
samuel l jackson and angela bassett who
won for outstanding actress in a drama
series as for her acceptance speech did
you actually forget your child's name or
what happened there how do you make it
up to them i want to make sure i got
everything in there and i was doing
pretty good and thought really well on
myself and then i forgot like my size
thanks my family courtney
slater and brown went
brain dead for a second but uh yeah just
for a second but you caught me you
caught me
ah he will never forget that trust me
mama remember that night you forgot my
name hello
[Music]